and that agenda is is being
propagandized
by people in hollywood again it's it's
elitist in the media
and in hollywood and in government who
believe they ought to rule your lives
and decide what is morally okay and what
is morally not
and this is how you end up with the
specter of pete davidson on nsl snl on
saturday night live
telling people over the weekend that if
you're protesting lockdown you look like
a baby
i i'm noticing that pete davidson was
sitting on the set of saturday night
live
like a foot and a half from from another
human being while he was saying this
i saw the protest people were outside
the bar
shouting about freedom taunting the cops
chanting that they should arrest the
governor but it's staten island so i
assume that it was just like a typical
last call
and are you against these protests i
mean kind of but i'm also just happy i'm
no longer the first thing people think
of when they say
what's the worst thing about staten
island i take it that you found these
protests frustrating
yeah man they're making us look like
babies you know you know it's bad when
even people in boston are like
ah drink it home your quiz um
okay uh first of all i'm i'm still not
sure why people find pete davidson
humorous but
beyond that pete davidson is sitting at
his workplace
a foot and a half from another person
wearing a mask right a foot and a half
from another person wearing a mask but
he gets to lecture you about what you
ought to do and
his business i've noticed is not being
destroyed also you may have noticed
there's a live studio audience for snl
you know how
because they actually designated i'm not
kidding they actually designated
live studio audiences employees for
purposes of essential services
for snl okay so it only applies to the
little people it only applies to little
people like you
you own a business you want to spend
time with your family the rules must
be applied to you and you are a bad
person if you buck the rules or if you
protest
the the level of arrogance that is
applied to one half of the american
population is just
insane it's just insane and you'll be
ripped up and down by the way
if you note this so matthew mcconaughey
committed this grave sin
so mcconaughey uh happens to be he he is
on the left last i checked
he's a democrat i know that he's in
favor of gun control he spoke in march
for our lives
but he happens to be sort of more
culturally moderate and so he was on a
show with with russell brand
and he said the far left in hollywood is
arrogant toward conservatives and the
world just caved in on him how dare he
say this
because there is one thing that the left
cannot stand and that is someone calling
out their bull crap here was matthew
mcconaughey calling out their bull crap
and getting a bunch of crap for it
there is a lot on that ill liberal left
that absolutely condescend patronizer
arrogant towards
that other 50 you and you say hey we
want to get out
with the vote we want people to go be
able to go vote we're going to do a
campaign to let people vote
i'm like 100 yes everyone is there
anyone who would say no to that
and then they can't help themselves at
the very end of it they go
so we don't let those criminals
get back you're like no
don't say the last part you lost 50 of
your audience
okay mcconaughey got a bunch of crap
from people in hollywood for this how
dare he
because how dare he point out that
there's an entire other side to the
political aisle
this is the kind of scorn that hollywood
has for you this is kind of scoring the
media have for you and your politicians
right this this group of elitists who
all traffic in the same circles
these people believe they ought to rule
you from above and if you buck that
system in any way regardless of the
industry that you are in
then you will be called out and you will
be ostracized you'll be socially
ostracized and you get some more of that
in just one second because
you know it does feel in the united
states and it has felt for quite a while
i'm firmly convinced that this is what
the trump backlash has been about
i'm firmly convinced that it feels if
you are on one side of the political
aisle which is to say anywhere
to the right of karl marx at this point
but certainly anywhere to the right of
hillary clinton
that you are under constant assault
you're under constant assault from
authoritarian government
officials from a media that will lie to
you and about you
you're under assault from hollywood that
wishes to promulgate messages
that run directly counter to your values
you're under assault from social media
that censors your viewpoints
and from journalists who will go digging
through all of your old posts to find
something that they can
use as a club to cuddle you you're under
assault from corporations
and from your bosses who might fire you
if a bad old tweet is resurfaced
it feels like that it feels like the
walls are closing in and that is not a
coincidence
there is a plan from elitist to make the
walls close in on you
because they must they must achieve your
silence and they must achieve not just
your silence but your ascent
they want you to be complicit in the
destruction of your own values
that is the goal here and that is why it
feels monolithic that's why it feels
like a tsunami right now a cultural
cultural tsunami and trump was a middle
finger to that that middle finger is not
going to go away post-election
regardless of what happens regardless of
how this election ends up being
adjudicated
regardless of what the electoral college
does okay that that
push to take over all of the
institutions of power in our society
from government
to hollywood to academia to the
education system
to to them to all of the main outlets of
media to social media
that push is going to continue unabated
from the left because they're engaged in
renormalization of american values
they're engaged in institutional capture
so they can cram down on you a
particular agenda and then ostracize you
if you dare to speak
up against it i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content